[Music]
tom is with us in lima ohio hey tom
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave and ken it is an absolute honor
to speak with both you you too sir how
can we help okay so i'll just give you a
breakdown of where i'm at um and then
i'll get to the question
i'm 19 years old getting married next
year
um i have a hundred and eighteen
thousand dollar net worth and here to
break that down for you i got 52 000 in
non-retirement 11 000 in roth ira
25 000 in savings 28 000 in a paid for
truck
two thousand dollars in a paid for car
and i have zero debt of any sort wow
how did you pull all that off at 19
um i mean i guess i would contribute
most of that to my grandfather he
introduced me to his show about two
years ago
and he's just helped me out between
him and you guys just a lot of
inspiration there and a lot of working
hard in savings what do you do for a
living
i'm a welder okay what kind of money are
you making
i'm making about 55 000 a year at 19
years old good for you when'd you start
welding
um i started welding i'm in a factory
whenever i was 16 through a school
program um working second shift after i
got off school
and then as soon as i got out of high
school i went full time fantastic
there's a great story dave of the trades
you are a stud yeah i love it how can we
help you sir
so my question here today is my
grandfather's farm
he is 72 years old
and he's uh getting closer to
finally admitting that he's ready to
retire and slow down a little bit so
he wants to sell me the farm
i'm about the last one in the family
that's interests in it
the farmer's worth about 1.1 million
dollars and he's asking hundred thousand
for it um and then there's probably
roughly a hundred thousand dollars worth
of equipment that i would have to
purchase off of him over time he wants
fifty thousand dollars down
and he wants to do a uh land
contract i think is what it's called
at the minimum required interest rate of
1.2 over 15 years
so i guess my question there is
i want to make sure that this is a good
financial decision for me if this isn't
going to be too much for me to take on
um with getting married next year and
and wanting to start a family after that
the farm brings in about 30 000 a year
so after that
the actual
mortgage payment so to say on it
would only put me at about 500 to a
thousand dollars a month out of my own
pocket
and i would plan on tackling that way
faster and hopefully having it paid off
in about five to ten years
do you want to be in the farm business
yes
not welding this is what you want to do
well i want to own the farm i still want
to keep my day job of welding and then
it's about a hundred acre farm so it's
i mean grandpa's always just done it as
a hobby he always drove truck over the
road full time
and then farm too so that's kind of what
i'm wanting to do is just
have this as a way life i guess
um so i guess the question would be is
you know
i guess based off these numbers it i
don't know it's just a lot to bite off i
want to make sure it's not going to put
me in a
in a bad predicament
where do you live
yeah i still live with my parents until
i get married next year how much is your
wife going to work outside the home
yes she's going to bring in about forty
five thousand so that'd be we have a
hundred thousand dollar household
you're going to live on the farm
yes it has a house on it
yep okay
probably about uh 17 or 1800 square foot
brick ranch home okay
and what's the rest of the family say
about you getting this at 50 discount
i mean they're all on page for it so
over the last year we've had a lot of
family meetings where grandpa sat down
all the kids
offered it to all of his kids first none
of them really
spoke up as interested um
but you're getting a 1.2 value for 500.
yes
okay
all right yeah and he offered it to all
of his kids nobody wanted it
nope no i mean none of them really
have i'm i'm taking it i got to make one
adjustment
there's no way under the sun i'm doing a
land contract
okay they're dangerous let me explain
what a land contract is it's called a
contract for deed the deed is not in
your name
you have a contract that gives you the
right to the deed when you pay the
property off if before you pay the
property off the owner of the property
were to get sued
and have a lien placed on the property
they would not be able to transfer the
deed to you even if they wanted to your
grandpa falls asleep at the wheel and
hits somebody head on and they sue him
for 500 million dollars for a wrongful
death you lost your farm and it wasn't
your fault because it was never in your
name don't do that
okay
or your grandpa dies and all of a sudden
his children's memory of the fact that
they didn't want this farm goes sideways
and the property's not in your name it's
a contract now with an estate that is
now in dispute because your uncle lost
his freaking mind when he found out you
bought it for 500 instead of 1.2
yeah
and this has never happened in any
family right
say it again i said this has never
happened in any family
yeah i'm sure the property goes into
your name
or you don't do the deal and it's called
a mortgage then it's not a land contract
okay it's an owner-financed mortgage on
the terms that you outline and then no
one can take it from you as long as you
abide by the terms of the mortgage and
if you don't then you could get
foreclosed on by the estate which will
be the owner of the mortgage
your grandpa's estate when he passes is
who you will owe the money to
okay
and then you go out there and take all
the ot you can get and bust your butt
and pay this thing off
that's a plan because it scares a crud
out of me but there's so much that's
right here that i'll overlook a couple
things that are wrong i will not
overlook that land contract i would beg
and plead with you not to do a land
contract
okay i think i outlined all the risks
clearly didn't i
yeah i do believe so
[Laughter]
tom you're a strong young man yeah
that's a powerful place to be at 19
years old
uh you're biting off a really big chew
here yeah i'm a little nervous about it
yeah it's a lot of chew it's a lot of
hobby here's the thing that's what he's
saying listen to me it's in his name
that's true
four years from now you're right it's a
nice asset you can sell it for 1.5 if
you decide you're over there you're
right i love it if it don't if it don't
work out it's going to work out that's
true it's good real estate